an estimated 25 million American adults
use dating apps in the past year a
recent study finds at about 39 percent
of heterosexual couples and about 65% of
same-sex couples who met in 2017 did so
on the Internet despite that some
experts say these dating apps keep
people locked in an endless cycle of
matches and rejections and many end up
feeling more disconnected and lonely
than before
the new CBS n originals documentary we
calling it speaking frankly dating apps
looks at the benefits and the downsides
of technology driven courtship here's it
here's an episode the more that you say
that you're interested in a person and
you hear back that that same person is
interested in you that can be a little
bit of a rush and a reward that kind of
makes you want to continue using that
app a lot of the times I was constantly
checking my notifications every time I
would try to do homework or something
and once I hear that sound I would
constantly look at my phone see who'd
messaged me see who responded even times
when I was trying to go to sleep I was
constantly looking or seeing if somebody
messaged me back or what messages who
messaged me or what message that I
received I think part of the game is
trying to figure out what the other
person wants and then that's when you
win it's when the person says like yes I
see I see what you're selling me and I
want it I hear from some of my friends
who use dating apps that they are
exhausted they find the process to be
very time-consuming not as enjoyable as
one would hold so I think part of the
burnout just comes from being
overwhelmed by choices having too many
opportunities not actually meeting up
with people and engaging with our phones
more so than with each other there's a
problem that social scientists have
named the paradox of choice and that is
that we think having lots of choices
would be amazing and get us exactly what
we want but it turns out and many things
the more choices we have the more
miserable we become so we think we're
excited about someone and then we swipe
and there's another amazing person who
appears we make a mistake which is that
too many people think of the faces on
their screen as options the truth is
you're not an option until you show
for the date and express interest in
someone basically most of the time
you're just a bubble on a screen the
executive producer producer of CBS n
originals that's Adam Yamaguchi joins us
now I love everything that they said
right there why is it why is it making
us more lonely to have all these options
and choices aside from the paradox of
choice or the paralysis of choice
paralysis that many people face is is
this phenomena of deindividuation and
and and the experts sort of alluded to
it on game D individual so when you're
on your phone you are shielded by your
screen your avatar is your proxy and
there's a veil of anonymity so people
are likely to engage in behaviors that
they might not in real life yeah and we
see this across social media this isn't
just a dating apps phenomenon and so
over time you know you begin to treat
other people not as people but as
objects or as options it becomes almost
like a video game for people absolutely
and and and before you know what you're
mindlessly treating it like a video game
and you're swiping swiping away and
what's interesting is that a lot of
these these apps have they've been built
from the ground up to feel like a game
color schemes the graphics the sounds
that come in when someone shows an
interest in you is gratifying you were
talking earlier about Instagram and the
sort of gratification that comes with
likes what's very similar on dating apps
so how do you make it positive Adam well
I think one of the things is you know
people so people can burn out but
experts say look you're on a dating app
for a reason you know you've lost sight
of what your goal is but if your goal is
to meet somebody you know there are
tried-and-true practices of courtship go
back to those people like people stream
the cbsn original speaking frankly
dating apps right now at CBS n.com
[Music]